Trump 2024 may be dying before it even
starts in multiple new 2024 Republican
polls Ron DeSantis is leading Donald
Trump and this is before Trump makes his
big announcement tonight which we will
talk about in a moment there are two
arguments about the importance of this
which we will talk about in a moment
first and foremost there is a you gov
America poll and it asked Republicans do
you prefer DeSantis or Trump in 2024
Republicans and Republican leaners say
42 percent Ron DeSantis 35 Donald Trump
10 neither 13 not sure now the neither
and the not sure could make the
difference and push it back to Trump but
we are now for the first time getting
these types of numbers this poll was
conducted November 9 to 11 meaning it
was after the 2022 midterm and indeed it
would be a logical causation to infer
although for now we can say it's a
correlation it could be a causation that
Trump's controversial and sort of like
contested
endorsements in 2022 that went bad that
includes Kerry Lake although we didn't
know about that until yesterday
um mehmed Oz Doug mastriano Etc that the
failure of those endorsements has
reinvigorated support for someone other
than Trump now you might say well David
Sir with total respect and tears in my
eyes that's only one poll well there are
now multiple polls that show DeSantis
leading yes there's a new morning
consult poll in which Trump is still
winning
however we now have a CWS research poll
in Texas which shows Texas prefers
DeSantis over Trump 43-32 that's a
pretty big deal we have a Georgia
Republican primary poll from WPA
intelligence which shows DeSantis plus
20 over Trump we have one in Florida
which shows DeSantis plus 26 over Trump
New Hampshire DeSantis plus 15. Iowa
DeSantis plus 11 and one from the
association for Canadian studies for a
general National primary which shows
DeSantis plus two
this splits this changed right after
November 8th now there's two arguments
here argument one is that this is all
completely irrelevant okay the argument
that it's irrelevant is
if you actually have Trump and DeSantis
running an ugly contested
snippy primary against each other Trump
will do the same sort of stuff that he
did in 2016 making fun of people
ridiculing them being Teflon and that
ultimately DeSantis isn't going to be
able to do it and that DeSantis is going
to fall off
there are some major differences however
number one
if indeed this is a two candidate race
Trump versus DeSantis that's very
different than what would have happened
then what did happen in 2015 and 2016
which was you had 18 candidates or 19
candidates to start with you had a lot
of these ones and twos people polling
one and two percent and Trump just would
stick it out long enough for one of the
ones and twos to fall off and Trump
picks up a point
and then another one of the ones and
twos falls off and Trump picks up
another point or two there was this
attrition sort of dynamic if you just
start with really just two candidates in
2024 Trump and DeSantis with Trump being
a known political entity with Trump
already being president with Trump
already losing himself in 2020 and
hurting Republicans in 22 you can argue
the circumstances are so different
that it is not going to be a similar
situation but for the first time the
betting Market's now pointing to
DeSantis over Trump in the primary and
increasingly polling pointing to
DeSantis over Trump tonight is the big
announcement before you go if you
enjoyed this video and want to see more
please make sure to subscribe to my
YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description